[Music]
you see these stories in the news and
we're all talking about the big stories
these days there's a Supreme Court
there's the city in Nevada going on a
lot of big stuff but then ever down then
it's a story that's just kind of weird
catches your attention absolutely true
a man is currently touring the country
in his custom-designed sports car that's
made entirely of cannabis yes he may
look at it that sports car is made
completely out of cannabis he calls it
yeah his cannabis car
what who said who said lame did you say
lame lame dude all right well I'm sorry
this is our cameraman
Robbie Robbie I'm surprised you think
that's lame
especially since all you do as far as I
can tell is smoke pot 24/7 so why would
you think that's lame well that's not
true man I also eat it anyway that car
is weak dude you think the car made
completely of cannabis is weak do you
think you could do better can and have I
built an exact working replica of a
vintage 1957 BMW r50 motorcycle entirely
out of Northern Lights cush you built
you built a moment if you actually built
a motorcycle out of marijuana that's
impressive how long did that take you
like 13 years but she's a real peach man
check her out
let me grab oh I'm sorry that is that is
not a motorcycle what do you mean come
on Robbie how high were you when you
made that thing cuz it just kind of
looks like a tree went to the back no
it's ridiculous if you ride that thing
or just put salad dressing on it is your
helmet just like a giant acorn yeah hey
careful dude I think some hummingbirds
are nesting in your bike shut up guys
just shut up
guys are dicks let's get out of here
Kathy this doubt me you see
[Music]
[Music]
I'm the bow-wow it's my third appearance
on the show hungry though here you go
tutti-frutti sir he-man you don't look
so good Bobby are you okay man I crashed
my bike no you never even got on it you
just you just walked over there and fell
asleep I can't feel my legs man
well should we call an ambulance no I've
had a good run
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you